foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
ba bets we love welcome to the show
everybody Welcome in welcome and get
those fingers ready because we are going
to need some locks we are looking for
locks
let me introduce you guys to the people
that are next to me you guys might know
them already my name is Greg Ivory next
to me is the man I like to call
MB you might know him as Michael Bolton
he's the man of the app and then next to
him
is uh say it Purdue for producer
one of these days man one of these at
least you're not calling me the rat this
time no that's just the chat I didn't
make that up I know you make that up I
know you didn't make that up I would
like to say I tried to ban bagel and
locks from this Show's chat uh it didn't
work I don't have that much power around
here so he's back in here call me the
rat That's What It Is Well last week you
know last week we did a parlay and it
was ruined by you right
look over took over as always I tried to
stir it your way and you know let's make
sure we tell the people that the the
Ryan parlay is 0-1 officially our
parlays have a different record the
self-proclaimed man of the people parlay
is all in one but we are here we're here
today we're here today Ryan uh-huh
yeah
so drop your Best Bets for tonight uh
TNT games we are rocking with the TNT
games only today and that's the Celtics
taking all the Nets in the Mavericks
taking on the Lakers Ryan
hop into the chat what are the people
talking about brother so I got two
comments I want to highlight that
happened before the show started uh B
Thompson jumped in here early said you
guys got to trust me on at least one leg
tonight I'm always money but y'all never
use my plays Luca eight plus assists I
know y'all
scared of the risk okay we're not scared
all right we're just we we like a little
easier play otherwise do the nine
assists and then before I get to before
we get in darien85 jumped in here and
said we need a winner y'all trying to
take my lady out to a nice dinner if
that's not too much to ask for it not
much to ask for at all I love the energy
that b Thompson brings yeah I kind of
like that play but yeah let's just jump
right into it right in Luca assist
I think he can get it
all right so I got some notes this week
because I'm definitely trying to get
this bread yes sir he is hit over eight
and a half assists in seven of his last
ten games so that's pretty good numbers
I know that Greg's new usually the
numbers guy so sorry I'm not trying to
take your shine homie nah do your thing
brother but I just want to win so bad me
too
I don't know if you have these stats on
the ready but the three aims that that
number didn't hit did it at least touch
eight or how many of those were under
eight I can go back and look it was
always pretty close though I mean you
gotta think right the Lakers are a very
bad team in my opinion I think they're
playing better now recently yeah but a
lot of onus is on LeBron to carry them
ads not back the only thing that I think
May ruin this one is if it becomes a
blowout but I don't really see that
happening tonight yeah I agree I also
agree that the Lakers are a very bad
team they are the worst team in
California and that's saying something
the kings are in California
I like the bean like don't be
disrespectful Ryan we ain't like no beam
you know who's not on TNT you know who's
never on TNT the Sacramento Kings Greg
there's nobody's watching that's not my
team I don't I don't you know that
doesn't affect me at all you know my
team is is is is is frequently on TNT
yes you know what I'm saying frequently
how on Earth did you come into this show
just locked and loaded on Sacramento
again I don't get it it's been a long
day somebody somebody's gonna need to
take the heat at Sacramento today again
that's it that's it hey we gotta send
you to Sacramento one of these days yeah
wow there won't be much to look at when
I get there uh can we lock it in Luca uh
so it just doesn't make sense like to me
it doesn't make sense 0.5 is like
drastic as far as it nods
uh my only take on this again is
avoiding a bad beat
like if he finishes with eight we got it
at eight
and it's 2 30. like 2 30 isn't bad if we
jump and take something else you know
what I mean so the only reason why I
agree with you right now Ryan because I
know where Greg's coming from is that
this is our first leg so we got to see
what else we pick and I think we're
gonna be in a good spot but we can pick
some more if we pick more conservative
legs we're gonna have to use that hook
tonight okay uh all right let's go back
to okay yes let's get back in here I
gotta I got a tip from uh miguelito 11
in the chat earlier in the day who told
me that the Celtics on no rest this
season beat their opponents by an
average of 12 and a half points and
Jason Tatum averages 36.8 points in
those games so I say let's get back over
to the to the Celtics and Nets game what
we're not gonna do fellas yeah and
ladies everyone in the chat is we are
not betting on Jalen Brown at all his
question able and even if he played I
don't want to bet him for the rest of
the year because that man be selling
he's like that man he's the worst he
bought last game he bought last he
didn't get like 40 or something like
that 41. he he also wasn't one of the
ones who didn't cash for us last time it
was Luca that sold and it was Jason
Tatum that sold but we're back on the
Tatum train uh no you're back on the
Tatum train line we didn't say anything
about Jason Tatum so you decided to go
to this game you decided to click over
to the Boston Celtics and Brooklyn Nets
you didn't even read a comment no like
what are you talking about
you no no no no no let me know I gotta
finish this you brought up a comment
that you that you preached
it was sent to me earlier in the day
exactly you brought in a comment that
was sent into you earlier in the day you
already knew what you were gonna come
and do it with this Greg Greg did you
see the comment because I didn't see
them
earlier in the day it wasn't in the chat
it was I got my little people who come
into my DMs and say hey you should push
this propaganda tonight and sometimes I
say and that's exactly what you came in
here and did you pushed the propaganda
from previous like we got people in here
filling up the chat with like takes look
at we got Dave Vincent over three and a
half assists I don't even know if I want
to rock with that no because it's not a
TNT game good 20 points we got we got we
got uh a lot of more a lot of more
people in here talking about other
things than what you're talking about
right yeah well they're talking about
James Harden assists and Joel embiid
points and I can't I don't know how many
times I gotta say we got a whole graphic
up here that says only TNT games I don't
want to yell at the chat
sometimes you gotta yell at her
Kyrie over 26 points see this is this is
what this is where this is where things
go bad because we got DJ Mari 10 saying
showing no love to the real comment
section shaking that's what I'm saying
that's what Ryan comes in here with his
propaganda and takes over did we lose
every parlay because Orion wants to take
over and uh we're not doing that today
suggestion look at if Greg man of the
people right the people decide who's the
man of the people you know what I'm
saying you you don't
man Ben Simmons triple double see
looking we got technology
[Laughter]
but in all seriousness though Ryan like
seriously
I've seen this I've seen this comment
last week okay I seen this comment the
week before and we never ever talk about
it Christian Wood over 20 points
but okay to be fair when they dropped
the Christian Wood prop last week it
didn't hit and I don't think it didn't
come close am I correct your parlay
didn't hit either I I know I know what
are we but you're bringing up two things
that didn't hit my parlay which was the
chats parlay and this
was
go ahead we gotta let we gotta let the
people dictate that's what I'm saying
right
we got Ryan the rat in this chat again
and this is
unbelievable right we gotta let the
people decide Kyrie 25 points my boy B
Thompson said it yeah let's take a look
at it I like B Thompson like listen b
Thompson I want to take your legs you
won't find somebody who's more anti-kyry
than me and he doesn't play well against
Boston he's just in his own head he
doesn't the only time he played well
against Boston was game one at the
Garden uh this past year
all right what about Nara D de Riley
says Thomas Bryant ten boards
Thomas
that's a lot foreign
shout out my man ksx Steelers ex first
time viewing and these guys have me
rolling welcome to the show well yeah
welcome to the show Welcome
[Laughter]
uh uh let's see
we've got a Ryan the rat burner with a
picture of me that says I'm a rat
there is listen this is crazy because
there's more rats in this chat than
there are in New York City and that's
saying a lot man
this is pretty bad for you Ryan you know
what I'll take I will take King of the
Rat I I if I'll be king of the rats
forget about mad of the people King of
the rats that's me yeah do it just own
it
Thomas Bryant Thomas Bryant what were we
talking about him yeah
so the original play was 10 boards um
listen he's kind of been pretty
important for that team I think recently
especially with A.D out so
I don't know what his number is set at 9
10 seems like a lot but
I don't know you're in a game against
the the Mavs who shoot a lot of Threes
so there could be a lot of long rebounds
and he's definitely an active rebounder
so maybe it's worth a play looks like
it's uh does that say nine and a half
yeah it's nine and a half what about his
points I feel like he's he's he's
they've been dishing him the ball he's
been scoring he's a scorer he's 16 and a
half I mean there's that's high okay
uh
uh I'm cool with it
I mean I'm about to go pull up his uh
his recent numbers just so it makes
sense and and Ryan I just want to let
you know this this was the 15 plus
I saw the people okay I'm just trying to
show you the way I'm all right you're
just acting like the stats that I'm
bringing like I I I it gets sent to me
Greg I don't know what I don't know what
to tell you
yeah but that was before the show
oh so the so the place before the show
don't count yeah we have a whole
audience right here we have a whole
audience that are like trying to tap
into the show you know and you're a
producer you know our objective is to be
interactive with the audience that are
here okay all right I'm not I'm not
saying the guy's not here now I'm just
saying it got sent to me earlier all
right so darion85 is in the chat saying
that's too high 15 is too hot I like it
simply for this reason let me let me
just say this the original play that was
sent in was rebounds I agree that he has
been scoring a lot so I'm not sure that
it's too high but the play was rebounds
originally
can I just read his
little in like the last 10 games 10 plus
yeah
29 19 21 2018 19 20 like
15 points so then 10 10 plus is a lock
then
oh yeah 10 plus is the absolute locked
all right so then I think we're good
all right let's rock let's rock that is
that easy I love it if you like it I
love it I love it I love it and let's
let's remember now we do like the 15 but
we do love the 10 so if we get short
odds we could bump that up
yeah good good call MB that's a good
call I mean
his rebound numbers are pretty good too
guys I'm just saying you guys are
talking you're gonna make this the
Thomas Brian parlay because I don't hate
it I don't hate it I'm just saying
let me be clear about one thing we
discussed this before the show so for
the chat that's listening right now I
want to get to the second game so bad so
if we only have one player from the
first game I will not be mad about it
hey right also also there's like six new
burner accounts so I don't know how
you're doing this Ryan but we've got
ratty Ryan we have we got a key correct
King Rat one we have Brian King of rats
this is actually remarkable and they're
pictures of me from this show
in this shirt
qualmir cook said Ryan Splinter so if
you're a Teenage Mutant Mutant Ninja
Turtles fan then you should get that uh
Jaquan says just check the plays so it
seems simple if you don't want to be the
king of the rats just like do what the
chat said yeah it's right it's that easy
it's that easy hey Ryan I got a question
what's up man can we parlay the uh
Thomas Bryant double double uh I don't
think we could do combos but uh as as
the man of the people I will check
hey
you keep pushing that huh no okay now we
can't we can't we can't no okay I like
this though I like this as a yes I I
will say we may need to stretch the
boundaries of what we do in this net
Celtics game just
because we need we need to get it we
need juice right time out time out time
timeout granted 30 seconds go ahead
we haven't seen a win in a while right I
mean not a while I don't want to say
that like we we win we win in our own
ways but like you know you took over
these parlays and we haven't seen a win
in a minute you know what I'm saying
um yeah we went in our own way but but
you also you also pushed this propaganda
of a lot of juice
what if we like
didn't like go for so much juice this
time and actually just went for a win
maybe we just we need to see one go
through the hoop that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying if we're doubling
people's money then it's like I mean you
can't be mad at that it's always a win
can I can I can I just I'm really trying
to be active in the chat right now but
every time every time I look down I see
Ryan's new avatar for the burners pop up
like it's typing but I don't see you
typing that's because this is not me I
know it's not and that's really
remarkable that you have five burner
accounts that are all cooking at the
same time
and it's
they're new pictures of me the
distressed look of my face is literally
right there love that I did 10 seconds
ago oh my god there this is like when
buddy that's the same shirts you gotta
that's what I'm trying to say it's from
this show
oh that's so funny all right all right
come on let's get back let's get because
we were cooking hold on I know this is
like I will say this this is like when
like you kill like a a pregnant spider
and then just like all of the baby
spiders come out that's what's going on
right now in the chat uh oh my God we
need to we need more pigs
B Thompson asks about Kyrie's threes so
we need to we need to move on together
go ahead Greg what were you gonna say no
no I was just gonna say uh
just what is this what is this let's win
today
go to Kyrie's threes go to go to Kyrie's
threes three and a half that's
that's so many go to two go to like
what's what's one yeah what's one one
minus eight thousand no it's not gonna
work uh it brought the odds down
he didn't bring the odds down that's
super pretty
uh I don't I don't like that I don't
know if I like that you just talked
about Kyrie playing the Celtics yeah not
it doesn't play well uh hey go to your
boy go to your boy Ryan yeah your boy
Jason Tatum we're not doing it I don't
want to do threes let's do points I
think Jason goes off all right
listen if we're looking if we want juice
or if we want to win here's the here's
the difference here's the difference he
literally just walked you to this and
you are going through the door he walked
you to the door and now you're about to
walk through the door
I I like the door that we're about to
walk through
that's it I'm not knocking I'm opening
the door uh
I like
I like over 31 and a half I could be
talked into teasing it down to 25 and a
half I could be talked into T well I
don't want to tease down to 30. I think
he's gonna go over 31. I could also be
talked into 35 Plus
could you be talking to Robert Williams
eight rebounds he's starting tonight
after a game of rest because yeah but
fan did did a fan did a comment that
over 31 and a half I like it but God
sorry 25 plus Jason Tatum I like that 25
plus
yeah
Darion asked this Tatum slash Brown
playing it's a back to back uh like we
mentioned at the top of the show Jalen
Brown is questionable he may play he
also may not play Jason Tatum as far as
I'm concerned is playing
yes he will yeah he will play I'm I'm 90
positive unless something goofy happens
right before the game but I see this as
an opportunity for Tatum to really
show what he's got I don't know if he I
don't know if I'm gonna use Legacy game
the way you do but uh I used it a loser
it's it's very interesting because I
think a lot of the conversation around
him and being the MVP has kind of
quieted down a little bit but he's still
playing really well so maybe this is a
night where he goes off when his running
mate's not playing
hey Brian yeah I'm gonna uh take a step
into your playbook
and take over go ahead man let's cook
Robert Williams six plus Jason Tatum 25
plus give me those odds
okay all right
six plus
we're at geez this is this is gonna be
brutal Greg
I don't think it's gonna be brutal I
don't think it's good I think it's gonna
win plus 187. what are we doing that's
right
what if let me ask the chat uh Jay too
cool says uh Tatum 35 Plus what if we do
that let's just entertain it for one
second ready Ryan rat said let's ride
let's ride the Plus
foreign
what is it what's the odds is it plus
493 if we go to Tatum uh 35 Plus so if
we do uh Luca eight plus assists Thomas
Bryant 10 plus points Thomas Bryant
eight plus rebounds Thomas Bryant Legacy
game uh Robert Williams six plus
rebounds and Jason Tatum 35 Plus points
it gets us to plus 493. I trust you I
trust you okay cool wait a second 35
points too many points man I don't know
yeah I agree honestly honestly honestly
I like Jason Tatum I think he's really
good I wouldn't be surprised on either
side of this game if one of these teams
gets blown out tonight we got a lot of
people sitting for that uh for the
Celtics that doesn't necessarily mean
that Jason Tatum is going to score all
the points they might not he he shoots
terribly they might get beat by 15. so
35 just seems like a little too much
look at look at flyman said he's going
to hit 25 plus let's ride
I like I like the 25
if we start to negotiate this uh Thomas
Bryant Legacy game yeah and think about
putting in Lebron I mean like he's 35
points away from a career Milestone and
you know that corny ass LeBron knows
that he's that close yep so yeah maybe
we should put in National Television
I like the way you think MB I like the
way you think
um okay okay I can yeah listen we we
have like the skeleton of this parlay
I'm definitely down to down to negotiate
uh DJ Mori says Ryan has to have a long
shot and a parlay to feel good
I just need we just need somebody
that's somebody hey y'all can't do to me
what y'all do to Ryan man and uh why
what happened it's levels it's you know
what I'm saying okay yeah no don't start
that
[Laughter]
506 now
we don't like it we gotta we gotta get
we gotta move Jason Tatum down a little
bit yeah
30 Maybe
okay I don't hate that but it's not
let's do okay all right let's go check
on LeBron you could leave it in there
for now I'll do 20 we'll do 25. all
right so are we keeping Robert Williams
at six
like that okay all right so then let's
move over yeah this low-key is feeling
like a six leg parlay but I don't know
about you guys
yeah it is it is feeling that way
I'm starting to feel like the five
turned into a six because I like all the
legs we got I really do yeah and do burn
30 plus yeah I was just thinking the
same thing man
I yeah
let's play it safe
I like something no no that's enough 336
is it six legs or five legs it's six six
legs
oh
I don't know I don't know oh remember we
have something in the back pocket we got
Thomas Bryant 15 points and not ten or
or oh yeah yeah yeah we have Luca
Luca what I like the Thomas Bryant leg
better then okay you you like all right
so Ryan you were saying go Luca eight
and a half yeah let's do that I mean
well it's up to you guys I also like
hold on let's go chat here would we
prefer
Thomas Bryant 15 plus points rather than
10 plus points if we can get the parlay
on the screen in its current iteration
or
Luca over eight and a half assists
rather than eight plus assists so
there's a comment in here Kelly Bean is
saying make it eight since Ryan's
talking about spiders and that's pretty
I like that Vibe I don't know
against
no no man
I thought I was talking about the eight
assists versus eight and a half oh okay
all right do you want to make it Kelly
if you wanted to make it an eight leg
parlay just say the word and we'll do it
I don't make those promises uh beat b
Thompson said uh
Thomas 15 points so did Jaquan
make it 15 plus hey B Thompson B
Thompson can we make this your play
because I know you said you came in here
and you said no no just the Thomas Brian
he came in here and said you don't take
you don't take my picks I Thomas Bryan I
will I'm willing to give to you as your
pick
I see a lot of a lot I see a lot of
support at 15 for Bryant 15. okay so
this is what we have currently we have
Luca doncic eight plus assist Thomas
Bryant 10 plus points Thomas Bryant
eight plus rebounds Robert Williams six
plus rebounds Jason Tatum 25 plus points
I would also be willing to move Thomas
Bryant to the 15 plus
let's do it let's see what it looks like
all right
parlay
call it a parlay
I was wrong indeed Kelly Bean is
checking me and saying spider parlay
give me eight legs
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding yeah
hey
this one feels good yeah this one feels
good I don't know why do you have that
face uh
uh it's just it feels like why like why
are we doing like I don't know
six legs is a lot like we we just we
came onto the show and we were like we
were struggling to hit so let's hit
something and now I feel like we have
six legs just to have six legs when we
could have we could have just been
riding Jason Tatum 35 Plus points all
along
didn't we do 30. no we did 25.
that's cool wow yeah it's good all right
well all right well look at this take
out Williams rebounds and put Jason
Tatum 30 points and see we'll re-up
uh yeah you see you don't want to do
that no it's just like is that gonna do
much for us we'll see we'll see if it
what are you trying to do okay right I'm
trying to get us to at least plus 500.
that's actually no and that's the
problem that is the problem why that's
the problem
you're trying to force it you're forcing
it you're forcing it and every week you
force it and then
this is this sounds like pent-up
frustration from you Greg
I
thought why can't I you
you're using plus 500 when you don't
need to we we had to lock that plus
three years
no I like this
see because it's plus 500. that is
correct that is why I like it yes
Prince by Prince in the chat saying a
win is a win I gotta go with the people
in Greg tonight man we've we've done
your parlay the last three weeks man if
it's plus 480 for six legs it doesn't
matter because the money's gonna cash
and we're gonna have and my mandarian's
gonna get a chance to take his lady to
dinner are you wanna you wanna make be
responsible for him not taking his lady
to dinner I don't want to live with that
on my conscience uh no I don't I don't
want to be responsible for that I also
said I would like to do the same thing
yo what's up I'm sorry I didn't mean to
cut you off I was just going to read a
comment from the people no go ahead I
was just going to recap the parlay so
look oh rock paper scissors
Bandit Bandit zero one nine says uh
that's how you lose betting to get
specific odds the people
and you are you are a man of the people
D you have to listen king of the king of
the rats actually please
you gotta listen to the people
I am listening to the people
so make it make it plus 480 again so we
could get out of here
all right so like if if you're listening
to the people take Luca down the six
sixes no no no no we by the way also we
so this is a five leg parlay we have
four legs we have four we have four yeah
so here it is we have four legs in the
same in the same game we have Luca eight
plus assists Thomas Bryant eight plus
rebounds LeBron 30 plus points Thomas
Bryant 15 plus points and Jason Tatum 30
plus points do we wanna like that's also
my other thing here it's like here goes
Ryan I just like there's four legs in
the same game here you go
it's four letters
who cares
I'm seeing who cares
okay chat
this is a all right we'll scroll we'll
scroll through again
wait what did we take out wasn't it six
legs Luca
right what did we check out
we took out we took out Robert Williams
yeah we had six rebounds that that's a
lock that is a lot like yeah but it
didn't do anything for us it was like
minus three thousand
Ryan I don't think you understand man
that's
Robert Williams is made of
stand if we 'd be lucky if he finished
this game
he just rested for a whole game that
doesn't mean anything
oh my God I don't Greg I don't want I
don't want you to have to tell them to
put Ryan's parlay on here again but okay
it feels like this is what's gonna
happen is that what is come on man this
is happening week after week Ryan would
this make you guys feel better if we did
it this way if we added Robert Williams
no what we're gonna do is take Tatum
back down to 25. yes
tell him MB
can you go can can we do that please
I'll feel a lot better
thank you Ryan thank you so much
there we go boom plus 480. let's go get
this cash man so what is it what's the
bet what's the bet
let's do you hear the depression in his
voice just wait here comes a three two
one we have Luca dashish eight plus
assists Thomas Bryant a plus rebounds
LeBron James 30 plus points Thomas
Bryant Legacy game apparently 15 plus
points Robert Williams six plus rebounds
Jason Tatum 25 plus points that is six
legs yeah I like this 480. hey I'm not
gonna lie though I'm not gonna lie don't
lie
take Luca assist to six
[Laughter]
no we're not doing that
the only reason why we're not doing that
is because we got with it was the first
comment before the show even started so
he gave us eight that's three times
that's true that's be Thompson's leg
that's B Thompson's leg uh
Darian says I need some milk I have I've
hit
I wish I was at the by the fridge I
would have got you something
that's a chat chat thumbs up thumbs down
if we're good with this six leg parlay
at plus 480. double double O says LeBron
is not dropping 30 tonight in all caps
we're not what are we doing she's just
jump to plus 530 what what moved
Thomas Bryant of course and LeBron
my and Thomas Bryant again I'll take the
LeBron leg as my leg and I don't care
because he is literally just
he's just watching for this record that
he's gonna break I swear and he knows
that if he has 35 tonight he's gonna get
all of his followers and they're gonna
lose by 15. it's perfect I've already
watched it happen the only thing that's
like the only thing that like has me
second guessing or thinking okay this
parlay is Luca's assist
I feel like personally he's more
dependent as far as in a rebounder
than throwing assist because like he
scores a lot
uh rebounds uh sorry uh the snake said
six plus rebounds
oh snake versus
file that up yeah El Bay also says Luca
rebound so I don't want you thinking
that I don't pushing any propaganda Ryan
um no I see that's the difference
between you and I I don't accuse you of
pushing propaganda I listen I absorb I'm
like a sponge Greg I take everything I
take the hate I take the slander
we love you bro we love you
all right
I love you too all right six plus tons
of locks somebody said a sponge and
locks that's so funny
all right six plus rebounds nah it's
just like it doesn't 10 50.
ah guys what are we doing foreign
not for six legs not for six legs I
liked what we had before
what's the difference
like well like what's almost a whole
dollar yeah almost yeah wait hold on
what's his oh I don't like that oh wait
his assistant jump to nine and a half
that's good for us yeah so let's leave
it at eight before they move that [ __ ]
again
I'm about to get fired
you could you could curse over here yeah
you can I'm just fired up man I'm trying
to win and I think the eight is the lock
yeah I think so too I I like what we
have uh do we want to recap it one more
time and then again Final Call plus 5
30. yeah yeah oh yeah let's go
Thomas Bryant man is gonna the 15 plus
is really good let's give it no no this
Luca eight assists is really gonna sit
with me 86
so we don't what if you moved what if
you moved Bryant down to 10 now that
it's plus 534. all right
uh
this is scary this is scary I don't know
what we're
there was a big five gosh what happened
I don't know what happened yeah how do
we yeah
we feel it seems like we feel
significantly worse about this no I I
don't necessarily but I just don't know
why the odds moved so much like
anyway I'm cool with the I'm cool with
the Thomas Bryant uh 15. yeah me too
great The Lucas stuff moved in the right
direction for us I'm cool with Luca I'm
more cool and I was also that was the
one we kind of have to we OB Thompson
one
do you like that Luca player do you like
another one comment if you like another
one
he's like I'm really yeah I'm down I'm
down to keep it but if you like anything
else you just let us know oh he just
said when Luca ate assist hit and y'all
don't take it I'ma personally hit you up
Greg all right we gotta ride with it
yeah
15 points for Thomas Bryant is scary uh
we got Kyrie two plus threes in here
no the Kyrie we looked at Kyrie two plus
threes it's not it doesn't look good and
the Thomas for 10 points isn't good no
it's not what if what if we have we have
to have make a decision on time as well
right now do we just take his his over
under which I believe what is it 11 and
a half or something like that
okay wait
okay you guys are not gonna love this
what if we take what if we take the the
Thomas Bryant points out and we bump
Tatum to 30 plus
don't hate that here you go nah no Greg
this is it thank you boy thank you both
I don't hate that why
you don't care about winning Ryan you
true you don't care about winning you
don't you haven't showed that you just
care about going over 500 plus 500. no
I'm cool with this if we want to sit if
we want to settle on plus 461 with these
five that is what I will do
I'm cool with this let's take out Thomas
hey let's let's get let's get Thomas
Bryant templates points out of there
that's
no don't let's not do that I don't want
to do that
Thomas Bryant what is what is like over
under
Thomas because I'm seeing a lot of
Bryant 11 and a half points maybe 16 and
a half it was 16 and a half oh wow okay
yeah no we're good on that
I don't know how you guys find it out I
I don't dislike Jason Tatum to go over
30 points but it's just proves my point
it's just Ryan pushing his propaganda on
our parlay
we have to take the power from you at
least one week if he goes for 45 then
fine whatever
hey if you guys want to scroll FanDuel
then I was just gonna say next show let
me scroll FanDuel and uh
is ah man
I don't know Ivan Ivan Rana six says
Greg let him know we need winners only
come on man that's what I'm trying to
win I'm trying to win Ryan I'm sorry I'm
normally the middleman and I'm the
devil's advocate but it sounds like
we're gonna have to go back to 25 points
and we're gonna have to we're just gonna
have to ride with the original I think
that's I think that's the way hey look
at it look at ovs Rose 33 turn it into
Ryan's parlay eye rolls
oh God Jaquan Jaquan says Ryan is
pissing me off okay Juan what do you
want
like what do you what do you want though
hold you we won it Ryan we had it
you want Thomas you want the Thomas
Brian points back yes the people yeah
that's what we're doing
this so we're doing a six leg parlay
yeah
oh God
oh my God how upset you kidding it's
really funny
now we're getting to the troll we're
getting to the trolling part
of the chat now
did this okay okay Big Meech this guy
Ryan makes you lose place place the part
place the damn parlay now and call it a
day all right all right I'm taking
enough heat here I'll concede 15 plus
yes yeah
there it is all right there it is yep
yep yep yep there it is let's win this
when this hits I'm so I'm I'm gonna lose
it I'm gonna lose it somebody said OVO
Rose says if this turns into the Ryan
parlay I'm not tailing okay well guess
what it's not hahaha
oh over Rose Ryan lost US money last
week hey hey Darien 85 says guess me and
my lady eating at Wendy's for dinner
nah bro we go we go we gonna get you
right we gonna get you right
Ryan didn't have too much say-so on this
one
and that's the determining factor for
you
I mean the last three weeks I mean you
know what what what the people are
saying is they have more faith in Thomas
Bryant than they do on producer Ryan so
is tough
I've never been more disrespected on
this show before I will say that oh wait
wait hey it's all love can you read the
parlay one more time and then just know
that when this hits the chat is going to
be on fire next week I just can't wait
to see it I can't wait to see it all
right let's do this let's do it it's
Thomas Bryant eight plus rebounds LeBron
James 30 plus points Luka doncic 8 plus
assists Thomas Bryant Legacy game 15
plus points Robert Williams six plus
rebounds and Jason Tatum 25 plus points
plus 546. six legs this time not five
six
I say check marks by B Thompson he's in
favor and remember you're putting this
in on FanDuel you're getting your money
back if it loses but it will not because
Ryan Ryan had no say in the end of the
parlay so we're all gonna eat yeah we're
good it be
I feel real good about this one right uh
what man you oh you already read the
parlay you're read it one more time for
the people
read the parlay because he had no say in
it
I'll do it one more time just for you
Greg why not
a plus assist Thomas Bryant eight plus
rebounds Thomas Bryant 15 plus points
Jason Tate of 25 plus points LeBron
James 30 plus points Robert Williams six
plus rebounds plus 546 the chats parlay
the chat is all over the chat was all
over this one today Ryan you're gonna
sleep down for a letter tonight knowing
that like you had nothing to do with
this either way so I feel like this is a
win-win for you that is yeah yeah but I
don't know I have a lot of ammo now I
can there's a lot of blame that I can
pass I would never because Greg you know
this I'm not and I Told You So guy oh
you're a big one big I Told You So Guy
what's your record on this show
what do you mean it's a record it's the
it's a parlay it was no record no no no
no no no
you didn't get the joke you didn't it's
okay we'll move on if you guys want to
tell our five leg parlay make sure you
head on over to FanDuel and up into the
TNT Thursdays no sweat parlay for a free
bet if it loses
we're not grading any bets today we're
about to get up out of here
Ryan
they told me to have you read the parlay
one more time but I'm not gonna do that
to you
I'm not gonna do that to you the people
in the control room are clouding me just
as much as you guys by the way on a
daily basis I just want you to know that
they told me to have you read the parlay
but you guys see the parlay right there
uh Ryan did not have much say so in this
parlay so we are in good hands people we
are in good hands MB uh let's Get on Up
out of here Ryan and MB my name is Greg
Ivy next to me is MB I call him MB you
guys might know him as Michael Bowlen I
have to make that Claire he is the man
of the app and next to him is the man we
all love
we love you bro producer Ryan
AKA King of the rats AKA a man of the
people
hey we're up out of here y'all peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]